one of the questions i had is what's a
fat
shattering dimension and and did you
point that
and i didn't i didn't politically
correct
yes but fracturing director dimensions
are something from
um actually i won't even say that um
there's something from classical
computer science
uh i'm not i can't remember exactly what
context they were originally from
i wanna no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
say it and get it wrong but anyway
um but but uh they are like quite a
technical definition
um but what they really get at is uh
how um flexible a group of functions is
so by that i mean like how well would
they fit
various types of data if if uh if it's
just like a
a line right like if we're just talking
about linear functions they're not very
flexible
only um like you know very few sets of
data would
would uh fit a straight line um and so
if you're only allowed straight lines to
fit data
then you'll find that like mostly you
don't do a good job of fitting that data
but on the other hand if you suddenly
allow yourself like any degree
polynomials
um they are much more flexible and so
yeah um that this fat shattering
dimension is basically trying to
um like characterize different classes
of functions and how flexible they are
ah i see so it assigns them a number as
to how flexible
they are essentially